depression quest is a game slash
interactive fiction slash
choose-your-own-adventure slash new
media experience slash uh seriously the
lines between mediums has gotten so
blurred that it's totally awesome but
understandably confusing it's from 2013
it was made by zoe quinn patrick lindsay
and isaac shank ler in the game the
player assumes the role of a person
functionally themselves afflicted with
depression and is tasked with navigating
a variety of day-to-day activities with
the burden of illness it is an
absolutely brilliant example of the
merger of mechanics and narrative first
we need to lay the groundwork so let's
talk about limitations every video game
is a box it's contained it's bounded
it's defined by its limitations you can
only go to the places in the game that
have been built use the tools that have
been programmed in or select the options
that have been given to you these
limitations and rules form the game
itself the focus and push form the
narrative you can't negotiate with the
demons in doom because it's literally
not an option in skyrim you can't probe
yarl balgruuf for the kinky details of
his sex life because those details don't
exist in game not only is the option
never present the contingencies for its
presence simply don't exist the data
just isn't in the files and that fact
that something must be built in order to
exist is a wall that all games run into
this wall is so common that it forms the
underpinning of the basic language for
how we interact with games remember
every video game is a box when we load
up a game we go into the box where we
are presented with options we choose
which option we want and then the game
tells us what happens as a result for
the vast majority of narrative driven
games this relationship is incredibly
simple often bordering on being
reductive the game presents singular
goals that the player then executes get
to point a progress to point B choose
path C
or c2 this is not a judgement of that
arrangement it's simply the stuff that
games are made of and much the same can
be said about books or movies get to end
of page turn page read next page it's
not a bad thing by any means nor is it a
good thing
it's just a thing it's the mechanical
language that these games are written in
and anyone who's played several
instinctively comes to understand it
here's a waypoint that's where you're
expected to go here's an NPC with an
exclamation mark that's where you
trigger your next set of goals we have
become so trained and conditioned to
speak in this language and accept this
power dynamic that we now have a pile of
games like Bioshock spec ops the line
and the Stanley parable they call
attention to it by either subverting it
within the narrative or providing
players with the opportunity to subvert
it themselves and to the Doron is lived
this was not the correct way to the
meeting room and standing you it
perfectly well all of this the box the
wall the language and what the player
does with in between it all this is the
implicit substance of player agency
depression quest strips all that
substance back to its most basic form
that of the text adventure now I want to
do a call back here to something that I
mentioned way back in the first season
of the show in music videos 1996 to 2000
isolation we talked a bit about how
logistics can inform the themes of the
final product the example being the
video for Lisa Loeb song do you sleep
making things is difficult and
complicated and only gets more
complicated the more people that are
involved because the more people that
are involved the more coordination you
need just to keep things from grinding
to a halt there is a reason a lot of web
shows are made by one person in the
example video Lisa Loeb is the only
person to appear on camera and the
entire thing takes place on two sets
that are almost certainly about 10 feet
apart from each other in the same studio
space the isolated themes of the song
were supported by the logistical /
financial decisions to use a bare
minimum of resources depression quest
falls into the same realm the form of
the game a text adventure is a direct
product of logistical limitation
Quinn was working more or less alone on
the project for the vast majority of the
time and in her own valuation didn't
really know much about programming at
all and chose to build the game in twine
a free program for creating interactive
narratives that uses markup rather than
scripting or programming but it works so
well for the end product in a text
adventure the implicit substance of
player agency is laid bare in more
complex games the web of available
meaningful decisions is obfuscated by
other systems and methods of agency
expression even the simple ability to
wander around aimlessly in an empty room
does a lot to expand the player sense of
how free they are even if they're
ultimately just making their way from
point A to B it's a mechanism of the
suspension of disbelief in a text
adventure that's not present the player
is literally presented with a list of
all the available choices to pick from
and this is where depression quest does
something absolutely brilliant many many
many times throughout the game options
are presented as non options appearing
on the list but unavailable for
selection this is a beautiful merger of
the games mechanics the language of
gameplay and the underlying themes of
the game it is an explicit
acknowledgment that the box could be
bigger but isn't which is in turn used
as a demonstration that logical
decisions aren't always available to a
depressed mind often this narrative
device is used to communicate the subtle
nuance of the disease by demonstrating
the slight cognitive differences between
otherwise identical actions such as this
early choice where you decide how to
spend your evening outwardly choices one
and two are the same both resulting in
going out with your girlfriend but
shaking off the funk is simply
impossible in the same way that a
depressed person can't just snap out of
it the player cannot choose the first
option it exists in a void between
knowing and capability the game is
informing the player that it is aware of
the idea of the option but not providing
it depression and indeed many mental
illnesses create a similar gap between
what is known and what is perceived in
essence depression quest uses the nature
of its own mechanics
indeed the fundamental language of video
game narratives to communicate not just
the forms that depression takes but the
very essence of it the sense of robbery
that the afflicted has had something of
their personal agency stolen from them
normally narrative games go out of their
way to disguise those limitations hide
them as best as possible or distract the
player from thinking about them
depression quest puts those limitations
front and center openly stripping the
player of their agency in order to make
it personal so the question then is if
all of that is the box that depression
quest is built from what comes out the
other side the narrative follows the
course of about eight months in the life
of the protagonist who is you or a
depressed version of you the choices
that you make at each stage influence
the state of the narrative as it
progresses changing the mood opening up
or further limiting the options for how
you approach problems rather than trying
to encompass grand changes in a vast
network of possible futures the
narrative stays rooted in the plausible
the familiar exploring not just the
basic limitations of living with
depression but the deep ruts the near
paralysis and the unending monotony the
scenarios are ordinary in common
socializing with strangers coping with
an unengaging job managing relationships
with family friends into lover and then
doing it all over again it ends not with
a grand conclusion but a step back a
reflection of how your health has
improved or decayed over the months
based on the small incremental changes
that you made decision by decision day
by day this is a case where the
mechanics and the narrative are so
intimately entwined that they can't help
but drive each other from choice to
choice it is clear that there are
mechanical underpinnings game States
being tracked and all that but they're
communicated in intentionally vague and
generalized ways if your state decays
you watch as options close off the
decisions you make building the prison
that dictates if you're even capable of
coping with changes blocks of text at
the bottom inform you of your current
status and the haze of static grows more
or less intense as your condition
improves or worsens the exact results of
each choice are obfuscated and you're
left to your own judgment if you're
doing well you can always backslide and
no man
how bad things get you can always turn
it around the result is something that's
not merely impacting but authentic I
realized that that is a very personal
judgement but in this case it's almost
impossible to avoid depression quest is
to its core a personal game that asks
you to expose something of your own
fragility your own frustrations and
fears your own sense of powerlessness
even if you're on the road to recovery
the game still pervades a sense of
fragility and anxiety that you're not
actually improving you're just on an
upswing and at any moment it could all
come crashing down and yet for all it
slow grinding oppressive atmosphere
depression quest is fundamentally
hopeful believing that recovery and
stability are not only possible but
attainable even if you've never
experienced depression it is a glimpse
through a window at how the disease
grinds you down isolates you and robs
you of your power to act
it is a game about empathy the beautiful
thing about it is that this is the kind
of thing that can only be done in an
interactive medium that sense of robbery
of violation and limitation and the
elation of recovery of reclaiming that
humanity cannot exist outside the
implicit substance of player agency
that's important because this type of
depth this empathy game couldn't exist
in a different medium